Il y a deux semaines à Stockholm, un
ressortissant russe et un dirigeant de bombardier
comparaissent au tribunal.
contrat public en Azerbaïdjan en 2013, un
consortium dirigé par Bombardier a obtenu un
contrat de 340 millions de dollars américains financé
par la Banque mondiale, l'argent devait être
utilisé pour moderniser le chemin de fer national d'Azerbaïdjan. Les
autorités suédoises pensent que des pots
-de-vin ont été versés et que d'autres
dirigeants de Bombardier et la Suède pourraient également être
impliqué notre propre enquête montre
que l'affaire a de nombreuses ramifications
[Music]
s'il est expédié de Viloria en Suède
au consortium qui
consomme des frais généraux et à Bakou, c'est début
février,
nous rencontrons des collègues de
la télévision publique suédoise SVT et de l'
agence de presse TT  à travers les documents
qu'ils ont obtenus pour nous montrer à
Bombardier  intermédiaire mystérieux et mystérieux
pour envoyer des équipements en
Azerbaïdjan pour ce projet La
filiale suédoise de Bombardier doit
fournir des systèmes utilisés pour le contrôle
et la signalisation ferroviaires à une autre de ses
filiales en Russie mais les deux
contrats montrent que Bombardier en Suède
ne vend pas ses équipements directement à
Bombardier  en Russie, la
transaction passe plutôt par un troisième acteur,
une société appelée multiservice à l'étranger,
elle est enregistrée au Royaume-Uni mais nous ne
savons pas grand-chose de ses propriétaires, le premier
contrat montre que Bombardier Suède
vend l'équipement de signalisation de 46
gares à multiservice pour  environ
19 millions de dollars américains, puis plusieurs services
vendent le même équipement à Bombardier
Russie pour plus de 104 millions, soit une
différence de
85 millions.
ouais de retour à Montréal, nous avons examiné
chaque détail de chacun des deux
contrats  station par station avec le
Certified Fraud examinateur gagaga qu'ils
appellent : on regarde les deux contrats
on voit qu'il n'y a pas de changement entre
eux je ne comprends pas d'un
point de vue économique comment il peut se retrouver avec les
deux contrats identiques multi service
ne semble pas avoir fait beaucoup de travail, mais
le service multiple obtient la plus grande partie de
l'argent.
Regardez toute ma pensée, l'ultime
attente de mon peuple, les 85 millions, c'est difficile
pour moi de comprendre que
Bombardier se trouve aux deux extrémités de cet
accord et avec cette transaction.  ils
laisseraient 85 millions sur la table
qu'est ce que le multi service a fait pour gagner quatre vingt
cinq millions de dollars dans ces domaines
bombardier a indiqué à nos
confrères que le multi service c'était entre
autres s'occuper de la logistique
liée à l'expédition à la recherche d'une
entreprise appelée
multi service  à l'étranger à leur
adresse de Londres, aucun signe du bureau multi-services
ni d'employés de la
société d'enregistrement de Charles Russell, il y a donc
quelqu'un de th  à la société
ici en cherchant dans les papiers de Panama,
nous avons découvert que tandis que multi-services
achetait de l'équipement à Bombardier Suède,
l'intermédiaire a également signé un
contrat intrigant avec une autre société
Rambow management des
îles Vierges britanniques pour exactement le même
équipement, nous pouvons voir 13 stations
du 46  répertorié dans le contrat signé
avec le théorème des filets de bombardement si Rambo
fournit à la même unité cela n'a pas de
sens c'est impossible donc cela signifie
que l'un des deux documents est un faux l'
un d'eux est un faux considérez la
marchandise donc cela signifie qu'ils peuvent  't
coexistent dans la même comptabilité
impossible un buster
quand on regarde l'échéancier
de paiement de toutes ces transactions l'
objet possible de ce contrat avec rambo
émerge en avril 2014 multiservice
censé obtenir un acompte de
vingt trois millions de dollars de la
filiale de bombardier  en Russie dans les
deux semaines, multi-service promet également de
payer le même montant pour la gestion de la randonnée
7  sur leur curseur espéranto laplacien
cela signifie que les bénéfices ne restent pas dans le
multiservice, ils sont acheminés vers
Rambo Rambo aux BVI où le
taux d'imposition est presque nul pour les
sociétés offshore, il devient intéressant d'envoyer des
bénéfices dans cette société Sunita Hassan du
pétrole parce qu'il  pas un flic et regardez ça
ne s'arrête pas là, nous avons découvert que
presque simultanément une autre
société écran couronne le commerce avec les propriétaires et
pense recevoir à son tour quinze
virgule huit millions de Rambo
à Stockholm le procureur de l'
unité anti-corruption police Multi  servir a
été utilisé pour payer des pots-de-vin pour le projet
en Azerbaïdjan dans des e-mails de bombarder être
déposé devant le tribunal les employés bombardant
décrivent le multi-service comme une coquille
sans véritable échange un véhicule pour siphonner l'
argent du secteur public dans
des poches privées
[Musique]
mais finalement qui  a empoché l'argent
des reçus de gestion rebelle de multiservice
à Londres, notre collègue russe
Olesya sh mcgoun nous aide à comprendre qui se
cache être  hind Brando donc dans les documents
avec lesquels nous travaillons nous voyons un critère principalement d'
opinion scientifique alexei
alexey est le propriétaire de rambo nous
trouvons également des traces de lui dans une entreprise de bombes
aux Pays-Bas cette
société néerlandaise est actionnaire d'une
entreprise russe dans le chemin de fer  affaires
aujourd'hui
Olesya rencontrera la boutique Gedman Goodman il
était banquier en Russie avant de
s'exiler à Londres par peur des
représailles de X partenaires commerciaux en 2012
il a survécu à une tentative de meurtre en Grande-Bretagne
il est pertinent car il connaît très
bien tous ces gens que nous sommes
enquêtant en ce moment, il a accepté de
rencontrer Alicia hors caméra, voici ce
qu'il pense de la transaction multiservice et Rambo
, l'ensemble du stratagème est le
moyen le plus stupide de donner une excuse pour
transférer de l'argent il y a
quelque temps, tout le monde a aimé ça
parce que personne n'a été puni pour  c'est
démodé quelque chose a cédé à
documenter ce qui se cache derrière le multi service
sera un effort d'équipe un groupe de
journalistes a découvert que le multi service
par  ent company a été impliquée dans
des transactions d'une valeur de millions de dollars
avec Alec secret même nous avons ce
système de prêt compliqué comme l'argent
va et vient d'une entreprise à
une autre alors vous essayez de - Natasha c'est un
vieux truc emprunté au système de blanchiment d'argent
prenez soin de vous  4 000 connexions similaires pour les
autorités fiscales plus vous ajoutez de couches
plus il devient compliqué de percer
ces couches organisation policière
séquestre domestique dans ce document
saisi et bombardé par les
enquêteurs suédois Alex secret même est
décrit comme faisant partie d'un petit groupe
de personnes qui y ont accès  à presque tous les
chefs de chemins de fer des pays de l'ex-
URSS et qu'avec de telles relations,
ils peuvent influencer la prise de décision
influencer les décisions, c'est exactement ce que
l'unité anti-corruption suédoise pense que
Lombardi a pu faire en Azerbaïdjan,
ils ont eu plusieurs
réunions officielles avec des représentants avant  l'
ère des achats a commencé, alors bien sûr,
ils ont été de connivence avec le
critères pour les solutions pour le béret
sur le chemin de fer le genre de
chose afin de faciliter la tâche de
Bombardier nous devons contracter un mobile
pour soutenir un organisme et dans tous les sens
Bombardier n'est pas une organisation à but non
lucratif si nous considérons qu'il n'y a aucune
raison économique de  laissez 85 millions à
plusieurs services alors cela pourrait être un stratagème pour
redonner de l'argent à certaines des personnes que nous
vous avons données des contrats le stratagème poétique du
modèle Edda cool sur un grand
contrôleur de consolidation de conception 2000ad
donc cela pourrait aussi être de la corruption
dans un communiqué de presse  Bombardier déclare
qu'il a obtenu le
contrat de l'Azerbaïdjan après un concours équitable et
ouvert selon le procureur chargé
de l'affaire
Les dirigeants de Bombardier en Suède ont
accepté une autre faveur pour remporter le
processus d'appel d'offres sur le dessus de la peau avec plusieurs
services, il dit qu'ils semblent également  ont
accepté d'inclure trans signal revita
et comme j'achète une entreprise sans
expérience en tant que partenaire dans le
projet, la personne derrière l'azer  baijan
company votre compréhension est que c'est
quelqu'un qui vient des
autorités azerbaïdjanaises oui c'est l'avantage pour
lui parce qu'en eux cela signifie qu'ils
auront reçu des revenus apparemment
ils ont arrêté des
journalistes dans la région donc nous
essayons de trouver quelqu'un d'autre aller à  l'
endroit avec l'aide de notre
collègue bosniaque miranda Petrucci et de son
contact en azerbaïdjan nous avons pu
approfondir un peu cette entreprise
à bakou le siège social est situé dans
cet immeuble à la porte de
ce qui est censé être l'adresse de
trance signal roberta il n'y a aucun signe
de l'entreprise l'un des collègues de Miranda a
également conduit près de la frontière
avec l'Iran jusqu'au village des aliments au début
où le propriétaire de l'entreprise
réside censément
c'est là que vit le propriétaire de trans signal
revita selon nos recherches
il est  un électricien dit qu'il
ne sait rien de ce que fait l'entreprise
personne ici ou à Bakou ne pourrait nous en dire plus
sur le signal trans  Rebecca, cela
nous laisse avec de nombreuses questions que nous voulions poser
sur le bargee, notre collègue joachim voleur
amok a essayé d'obtenir des réponses de l'un
d'eux, les cadres des barges en suède,
thomas, ils seraient fous, ils tomberaient de grand homme,
il doit mériter un jour doit être fait
nous  n'a pas bien chanté un duo, il a reconnu
sa signature sur l'un des documents
mais n'a pas voulu commenter davantage
il y avait aussi des questions
sur la salinité baka sur ce qui s'est passé en Azerbaïdjan sont
également posées par la Banque mondiale qui a
lancé un audit en 2013 le  la banque a
fourni 220 millions de dollars de
financement supplémentaire pour le
projet en Azerbaïdjan, la plupart pour payer cette
partie de signalisation, les 85 millions qui sont
allés au multiservice représentent plus d'
un tiers de ce montant total Bombardier
dit qu'il prend la question très au
sérieux et aide les autorités le
La société ajoute qu'elle n'a
jusqu'à présent aucune information sur un comportement illégal et
qu'elle prendra les mesures appropriées
si elle découvre un retour en stock  Holm,
l'avocate des dirigeants de Bombardier
arrêtés en Suède, affirme que son client
nie les allégations portées contre lui par les
autorités, quant au procureur Forsberg,
il concentre son enquête pour le
moment sur l'autre contrat de John,
mais il ne ferme aucune porte au fur et à mesure que l'
enquête avance.  avant il n'est pas
rare dans ce genre d'enquête
que l'on trouve d'autres soupçons ou
allégations qui pourraient nous amener à ouvrir
une autre enquête en
décembre dernier Le journal Globe and Mail a
révélé que bombarda a également
utilisé la société écran multi surf en
Russie nos collègues suédois ont également
obtenu ce contrat  relatif à la
Mongolie daté de février 2016,
il montre que plusieurs services étaient encore dans les
bombardements jusqu'à récemment dans ce
cas comme dans beaucoup d'autres l'histoire
revient ici en Suède c'est aussi ici que
l'enquête de la police suédoise a commencé
et pour l'instant personne ne sait où elle se
terminera